sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans zone europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de cette émission
l'eurodéputé christophe grudler sera
notre invité l'occasion de s'intéresser
avec lui à l'énergie nucléaire elle
représente un quart de la production
totale d'électricité dans l'union
européenne
ce jour là le 14 juin 1985 la signature
de l'accord de schengen entre la france
l'allemagne la belgique le luxembourg et
les pays bas les superstitions en europe
avec evelyne keller auteur du livre 300
une superstition celle opportun on vous
parlera des traditions liées au blé mais
avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout de suite
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
bonjour cécile combat tenir à jour vous
êtes la responsable du bureau de la
région normandie à bruxelles alors
pourquoi est ce que c'est important pour
une région française d'être représentés
ici à bruxelles alors je dirais pour
deux raisons principales la première
c'est que bruxelles cinq centres de
décision un centre où se décident des
textes législatifs
qui vont avoir un impact très important
sur l'ensemble des territoires des états
membres qu'il s'agisse par exemple de la
politique agricole commune là on est en
pleine actualité puisque les trois
règlements qui constitue donc la future
politique agricole commune qui va
rentrer en vigueur en 2023 viennent
d'être adoptée définitivement par le
parlement européen la semaine dernière
donc voilà pour vous citer l'exemple
d'une politique européenne qui concerne
de manière très très importante la
normandie et puis bruxelles c'est aussi
un centre de financement
puisque c'est ici que sont octroyé un
certain nombre de financements
qui découlent de programmes européens
que nous essayons de suivre ici à à
l'antenne vous avez plusieurs missions
ici à bruxelles la première on imagine
que c'est de faire le lien entre la
région et les décisions prises ici dès
qu'il ya une décision importante prise
ici pour pour la région qui la concerne
qu'est ce que vous faites alors
effectivement cette cette mission que je
qualifierais ou ce rôle que je
qualifierais d'interface entre la région
donc le territoire régional et et
bruxelles et les institutions
européennes c'est ça qui définit en fait
notre notre présence ici après c'est une
mission qui se décline en plusieurs
volets alors on est d'abord là pour
faire de la veille sur l'évolution des
politiques et des programmes européens
qui peuvent avoir un impact sur le sur
le territoire régional donc quand il ya
une l'adoption d'un texte législatif par
exemple où la sortie d'un nouveau
programme de financement eh bien on
alerte la façon la plus la plus claire
la plus pédagogique possible en évitant
de jargonner comme on le fait beaucoup
dans la bulle bruxelloise comme on
l'appelle donc on alerte nos nos
interlocuteurs en région donc d'abord
sont les
directions du conseil régional les
différentes directions du conseil
régional et puis les acteurs du
territoire
de la région normandie avec lesquels
nous sommes en contact il faut savoir
que on a une particularité
en normandie par rapport à d'autres
bureaux de représentation régionaux
français c'est qu'il existe qu'on
appelle la taskforce normande à
bruxelles la task force normande auprès
de l'union européenne c'est un
partenariat régional qui a été voulu par
le président de région hervé morin suite
à son premier déplacement ici à
bruxelles en tant qu'élu tout début 2017
et donc c'est un partenariat qui
rassemble sous l'égide de la région une
dizaine ou douzaine maintenant deux
structures du territoire régional les
cinq principales agglomérations
normande les trois chambres consulaires
les ports de normandie le medef les
universités etc et donc c'est beaucoup
avec ces acteurs là aussi qu'on
travaille c'est à ces acteurs-là en
fonction de la thématique qu'on va
diffuser de l'information sur sur ce qui
se passe ici
justement sur les thématiques donc on a
parlé de la politique agricole commune
par exemple quelles sont les autres
thématiques qui intéressent le plus
alors il y en a il y en a beaucoup je
pourrais vous parler de pêche il ya une
actualité comme vous le savez très très
forte en ce moment en lien avec le bras
exit et la difficulté d'octroi des
licences de pêche à nos pêcheurs donc la
politique commune des pêches la
politique de cohésion c'est à dire la
politique européenne qui vise à
attribuer les fonds structurels dont le
don le feder
la politique en matière
d'infrastructures de transport qui va
permettre d'octroyer des financements
européens pour des projets importants du
territoire normand comme par exemple le
projet de la chattière sur le port du
havre la politique en matière de
recherche et d'innovation
qui va
là pour la nouvelle programmation qui
vient de commencer début 2000 21 permet
d'octroyer des financements par exemple
pour l'adaptation des territoires
européens au changement climatique
voilà donc potentiellement le champ
thématique qui nous intéresse est très
large l'union européenne peut sembler
loin avec des dossiers parfois complexes
que vous faites pour accompagner au
mieux les projets normand ici impossible
alors déjà je dirais
on essaye de dédramatiser parce que
souvent bruxelles et vu effectivement
comme quelque chose d'opaque de
compliqué de lointains et pour ce faire
c'est toujours très intéressant de
pouvoir accueillir ici des délégations
de la région mais délégation très
diverses qu'il s'agisse par exemple
d'agriculteurs
qu'il s'agisse de
laboratoires de recherche de services d
agglomération et c'est donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a je parle au passé
puisque depuis mars 2020 c'est un peu
plus compliqué on bascule est plutôt sur
sous le format des des webinaires mais
on a vraiment très régulièrement et
assez souvent accueilli des groupes
d'acteurs normand ici à bruxelles
pour leur faire rencontrer des
fonctionnaires de la commission pour les
faire aller au parlement européen
rencontrer des députés et ne serait-ce
que visualiser un petit peu les choses
les bâtiments voilà donc déjà ça cette
dédramatisation c'est important parce
que ça permet de plus de plus avoir peur
j'allais dire parce qu'effectivement
premières réactions souvent se dire
l'europe c'est compliqué c'est en
anglais
donc on voit là on est là nous pour
accompagner alors quand il s'agit d'un
d'un projet qui recherchent des
financements européens
on va regarder dans quelle
cazes ce projet pourrait potentiellement
entrée sachant que schématiquement il ya
deux grandes catégories de fonds
européens il ya les fonds structurels
donc le feder le f est ce le fait amp
pour la pêche le font pour la transition
juste qui est un nouveau fonds qui va
être mise en place donc là ce sont plus
nos collègues en région directement qui
interviennent puisque ce sont les
conseils régionaux comme vous savez
qu'ils ont là la gestion de ces fonds
depuis une grande partie de ces fonds
2002 puis 2014 mais la gestion elle se
fait directement sur le territoire par
nos collègues en région et nous là on
suit les négociations qui aboutissent à
l'adoption des règlements européens puis
après on intervient beaucoup moins et
puis une deuxième catégorie de
financements européens
qui sont des financements sectoriel
c'est à dire ces financements qui
découle des programmes sectoriels de
l'union européenne par exemple dans le
domaine des infrastructures de transport
vous avez un programme qui s'appelle le
ix mieux le mécanisme pour
l'interconnexion de l'europe qui va
permettre de cofinancer qui est doté de
près de 25 milliards d'euros au total
qui va permettre de cofinancer des
projets d'infrastructure donc que j'ai
évoqué le projet de la chattière en
normandie sur le port du havre il ya des
projets ferroviaires aussi qui qui ont
pu bénéficier
récemment encore de ceux de ce
financement il ya un autre programme
européen de financement qui est très
important qui est le programme horizon
europe qui est un programme dédié au
financement de la recherche et de
l'innovation qui va beaucoup financer la
partir de 2021 l'adaptation au
changement climatique
là la résilience des climatique des
villes mais aussi la lutte contre le
cancer par exemple
voilà donc il ya un nombre assez
important de programmes sectoriels
européens et ces programmes là à la
différence des fonds structurels où on
sait que la normandie pour l'entièreté
de la période de programmation c'est à
dire pour septembre bénéficie d'une
telle somme avec telle priorité ces
programmes sectoriels fonctionne d'une
manière très différente c il fonctionne
par appel à propositions qui sont
pilotés depuis ici par la commission par
les agences exécutives de la commission
européenne et sans répartition
géographique
prédéterminé donc il faut avoir les
meilleurs projets pour avoir accès à ces
financements est donc là nous on peut
accompagner en des gens en identifiant
le plus en amont possible appel à
propositions qui va correspondre le
mieux possible à une idée de projet
régional qui nous qui nous est remonté
en aidant aussi le cac jc le cac jc loin
échéant à la recherche de partenaires
parce que souvent pour avoir accès à ces
financements sectorielle il faut monter
des partenariats avec des porteurs de
projets qui sont situés dans d'autres
pays l'union européenne donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut avoir des partenaires en
allemagne en italie
en règle générale c'est 3-3 partenaires
dans au moins trois états membres encore
faut-il avoir ses partenaires et nous en
étant ici on est en réseau avec
toutes les représentations régionales
européennes y en a beaucoup dans ma plus
de 160 et on peut donc donner faciliter
la recherche de partenaires européens et
puis enfin
dans le cadre de ces de ces appels à
propositions qui encore une fois sont
des appels assez compétitifs on est là
aussi pour s'assurer que le projet qui
sera déposée par des acteurs normands et
correspond bien sk temps là la
commission européenne et par les deux
représentations régionales ici vous
partagez vos locaux avec la région ile
de france vous échanger régulièrement
oui bien sûr baignade et des thématiques
que l'on partage notamment ce qui tout
ce qui tourne autour de la valorisation
de l'axé seine et la de la vallée de la
seine donc sur certaines thématiques
comme la thématique de l'hydrogène par
exemple qui est une thématique qui
montrent très fortement en puissance à
la fois en région mais aussi ici à
l'échelle européenne avec des
financements européens de plus en plus
importants qui vont être dédiés au
développement de l'hydrogène a manqué
trop gènes propres à partir donc de
cette période de programmation donc ça
fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
effectivement on échange avec nos
collègues de l'île de france parmi
d'autres sujets faciles d'avoir été avec
nous dans la zone europe je rappelle que
vous êtes le responsable du bureau de la
normandie à bruxelles avec plaisir
so d'europe ce jour là
ce jour là le 14 juin 1985 la signature
de l'accord de schengen entre la france
l'allemagne la belgique le luxembourg et
les pays-bas retour avec europe direct à
cause de la crise sanitaire nous avons
compris que certains aspects de notre
vie est considéré comme acquis notamment
l'espace schengen ne tenait qu'à un fil
un fils comme le fil barbelé très
typique de frontières ou les autorités
nationales exercer leur contrôle
pour rejeter ce qu'il n'avait pas le
droit d'y rentrer cette image est
peut-être un peu caricatural mais il ne
faut pas oublier que les frontières de
ce type était une réalité entre les pays
européens jusqu'à seulement il ya une
quarantaine d'années oui un certain
moment nous avions raison de craindre
que l'acquis de schengen soient mises à
mal par l'urgence sanitaire mais au fait
qu'est-ce que l'espace schengen pour le
comprendre il faut revenir au 14 juin
1985 quand la france l'allemagne la
belgique les pays bas et le luxembourg
ont décidé de trouver un accord pour
supprimer les frontières intérieures ses
seins pays se sont réunis pour rendre
effective la liberté de circulation en
supprimant les contrôles aux voyageurs
cet accord porte le même nom que la
ville où il a été signé schengen une
petite ville adossée au verdoyantes
collines luxembourgeoise et qui ne
compte que quatre mille habitants sa
particularité elle se trouve à
l'extrémité méridionale du luxembourg à
proximité du point de frontière avec la
france et l'allemagne dans cet espace
les voyageurs européens peuvent se
déplacer librement d'un pays à l'autre
il suffit tout simplement de se munir de
sa carte nationale d'identité et même
les ressortissants des pays tiers
peuvent se déplacer d'un état membre à
l'autre avec un seul visa le visa
schengen leur facilitant le séjour sur
le territoire européen en plus les
contrôles aux frontières extérieures
sont renforcés pour garantir à la
sécurité dans toute l'europe en 1990
presque tous les pays européens adhère
petit à petit à la convention qui
découle de cet accord et parmi eux mêmes
des pays qui ne font pas partie de
l'union européenne
dans tous ces pays les contrôles aux
frontières sont démantelés et ne sont
repris que de manière sporadique et
exceptionnel bien entendu ces décisions
de rétablir les contrôles sont parfois
faites de manière unilatérale et
injustifiée ce qui peut pousser la
commission a recadré les pays membres
décidons d'y avoir recours il est
important en effet que le principe de
liberté de circulation ne soit pas remis
en question dans tous les cas il
semblerait que schengen et fait ses
preuves lors de la crise sanitaire et on
espère pouvoir revenir bientôt à la
normale et voyager sans restriction il
est peut être temps de réfléchir sur sa
prochaine destination
zone europe l'invité politique
bonjour christophe grudler
bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés membres du
groupe renew europe au parlement
européen merci d'être avec nous dans une
europe vous êtes aussi membre de la
commission de l'industrie de la
recherche et de l'énergie alors
aujourd'hui avec vous nous allons parler
de l'énergie nucléaire dans l'union
européenne il ya environ 125 réacteurs
nucléaires actifs qui permettent de
produire 26 % de l'électricité dans
l'union européenne
en france ce chiffre monte à 70% pour 56
réacteurs nous sommes en france l'un des
pays les plus pro nucléaire au niveau de
l'union européenne comment est-ce qu'on
peut l'expliquer
mais écoutez il ya une tradition en
france il être de la tradition de
l'autonomie stratégique par rapport à la
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
notamment je rappelle que ça remonte
presque chocs pétroliers des années 70
ou pour se libérer du gaz naturel et du
pétrole qu'on apportait en fait on a
essayé de produire nous mêmes notre
propre énergie le contre électricité et
donc la france massivement investi dans
les années 70 et 80 pour arriver à ce
niveau de performance qui fait qu'avec
d'autres pays ont également subi et donc
on a aujourd'hui une situation qui fait
que effectivement au niveau électrique
on était à 70% dans le mix énergétique
au profit l'énergie nucléaire en france
ce qui est un avantage puisque en fait
c'est l'énergie est décarbonée il n'y a
pas de dégagement de co2 pour faire du
nucléaire et donc par rapport à
l'objectif du green deal m'a coûté en un
preneur en même temps et on a un
avantage stratégique peut-être pas
exploité par le président emmanuel
macron a pourtant pris la décision de
fermer le p r de fessenheim au début du
quinquennat mais en lançant le plan
france 2030 le président a exprimé son
souhait de relancer l'industrie du
nucléaire en france en construisant des
nouveaux petit réacteur c'est une bonne
chose selon vous alors oui un petit peu
de précision de fessenheim avait été
acté avant la présidence de minutes
macro et fessenheim est la plus ancienne
centrale nucléaire de france donc il
faut quand même que les centrales sont
là pour 40 à 50 ans peut-être 60 dans
certains cas et que en fait il y aussi
une logique à réinvestir dans des
vêtements du matériel neuf et donc le
difficultés faites par le président de
la république à l'elysée dans le cadre
effectivement de france 2030 sont une
excellente nouvelle alors il ya de tout
d'abord dans le cadre du plan de relance
et 500 millions d'euros qui vont être là
pour justement c'est smr small modular
reactor donc le nucléaire est le
créateur nucléaire de petite puissance
pardon et de l'autre côté il également
500 millions d'euros pour la recherche
et le développement pour avoir du
nucléaire plus performants pour ré
travaille également sur les déchets du
nucléaire parce qu'il faut lui dans les
réduire les recycler le plus possible et
peut-être ne plus avoir du coup d'ici
quelques années là encore c'est une
belle étape on va bien c'est un bon
début puisque là on est sûr sur du smrc
de la petite puissance et derrière il
faut effectivement delà de la plus
grande puissance on connaît l'importance
de l'industrie nucléaire en france en
termes d'emplois notamment le secteur
compte plus de 220 mille salariés et
3000 entreprises c'est un savoir faire
qu'il faut préserver qu'il faut
continuer à soutenir
bien sûr le nucléaire c'est la troisième
filière industrielle française donc il
faut évidemment le soutenir comme le
tome lui d'ailleurs qui est en pleine
mutation également en raison de l'arrêt
programmé des moteurs thermiques donc il
faut accompagner les secteurs en
mutation et puis il faut réinvestir
massivement dans l'ue car on n'a pas le
choix ah la la commission européenne
pour atteindre le green deal en 2050 a
donné un tableau avec une analyse qui
dit qu'en 2050 il faudra dans l'union
européenne dans le mix énergétique au
moins 12 % d'énergie nucléaire si on
veut pouvoir avoir un équilibre global
des d énergie pour totalement des
guerres connaît donc si on a pas 12 %
nucléaire eh bien on ne pourra pas s'y
est le glenn miller 2050 ça veut dire
réinvestir parce qu'en 2050 les
centrales des années 70 80 seront
arrivés en fin de vie donc si on ne
réinvestissent pas dès maintenant pour
des réacteurs qui ouvriront en 2040 donc
c'est pas un objectif pour le fitr
festif ait pour 2030 c'est un objectif
pour 2050 donc on a vraiment besoin de
le faire de ce lien appuyé hier le débat
sur le nucléaire fait des vagues en
france 24 de l'awb de la présidentielle
2022 à gauche on souhaite sortir de
cette énergie sortir du nucléaire et
misait sur d'autres énergies le
renouvelable notamment l'euro député et
candidat écologiste à la présidentielle
yannick jadot appelle la france à cesser
ce lobby insupportable pro nucléaire
vous avez vous l'impression en tant
qu'eurodéputé de faire du lobby
pro-nucléaire ici au parlement européen
j'ai surtout l'impression qu'il ya un
lobby insupportable antinucléaires et
que ça c'est une vraie catastrophe parce
que au nom du dogme on arrive à rejeter
une énergie qui des carbones
complètement l'objectif du green deal
était partagée par tous le le parlement
donc toutes les techniques qui dès
carbone avec une évaluation de l'impact
environnemental ce qui a été fait
également pour le nucléaire et
maintenant on n'en veut pas aux raisons
de vieux dogmes des années 70 qui êtes
nucléaire s'était pas bien donc c'est
tout bonnement une bêtise de réaliser
que de réfléchir comme ça moi je
souhaite la réussite du green deal et je
ne souhaite pas opposer les énergies
renouvelables le nucléaire c'est l'un
avec l'autre c'est pas l'un sans l'autre
donc en fait il faut un peu sortir de
cette réflexion de la génération d'avant
d'avoir encore celle des années 70 et
puis arrivèrent un discours moderne
discours moderne c'est qu'on a besoin
d'abord effectivement des énergies
renouvelables et comme elles sont
intermittentes ne permettent pas de
fournir les citer le monde en même temps
il faut derrière des énergies pilotable
décarbonés et le nucléaire est une
énergie qui de tap décarbonés coyah plus
devant mais on appuie sur un bouton et
en quelques minutes on arrive à avoir de
l'électricité pour tout le monde en
évitant le black out
or ce sont les états membres qui
choisissent de faire leur propre
production d'énergie donc s'ils ont la
compétence pour la choisir l'allemagne a
fait le choix de sortir elle le petit à
petit du nucléaire comment ça se passe
quel le retour vous avez pu échanger
avec vos camarades eurodéputés allemands
lors si moi je suis dessus sur très
triste que je regarde la halle même pas
ce qu'il y avait de bonnes intentions
des choses très positives comme
notamment les parcs éoliens dans
l'attique ses rentrées de 6 à côté de ça
ils n'ont pas de réseau ils n'ont pas de
réseau pour diffuser c'est cette énergie
renouvelable dont tout non plus
l'allemagne comme ils ont souhaité
sortir du nucléaire ils ont redémarré
des centrales à charbon des centrales à
gaz ils ne sont pas l'achat beau tout
neuf qui était inaugurée en 2020 donc en
fait en vouloir hâter nucléaire ils sont
obligés de reléguer du co2 et donc de
polluer un peu plus la planète donc en
fait il y en aurait actions actuellement
en allemagne qui est dira peut-être que
la fin de vie de nos nos centrales
nucléaires dont on va peut-être attendre
2000 on voulait le faire en 2025 en tête
en 2003 il ya aussi le même type de
réflexion en belgique et donc c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'il faut pousser la
recherche et de développement montrer
que le nucléaire de demain il peut être
encore plus vertueux on peut maîtriser
réduire voire supprimer les déchets
après le monde les travaux qui ont été
comme ça sur les lasers notamment qui
permettent de traiter les déchets donc
il faut vraiment qu'on soit proactif là
dessus c'est aussi pour ça que au niveau
du parlement européen nous avons lancé
notre groupe notre indice groupe de
réflexion sur l'avenir du nucléaire dans
l'union européenne pour permettre
justement de sensibiliser tous les pays
et puis tous les groupes politiques
cette problématique alors justement en
tant qu'eurodéputé l'une de vos
principales occupations c'est de vous
occuper de la législation pour améliorer
les normes de sûreté applicables aux
centrales nucléaires et à garantir que
les déchets nucléaires soit traitée
éliminé en toute sécurité dans l'union
c'est aujourd'hui vos principales
missions dans la dans cette commission
des dialogues
alors au niveau de la commission de
recherche industrie énergie et elles
m'ont recherche tout d'abord donc on va
d'avoir travaillé effectivement à
trouver de nouveaux process de deux
nouvelles solutions et puis également on
va travailler à produire davantage
d'électricité avec un minimum de
combustible ça c'est important la
première mission de notre d'autres
commission énergie c'est de fournir de
l'électricité et du chauffage à tous les
citoyens européens donc faut pas oublier
cet objectif crucial en tout cas on peut
le faire pour cette raison et parce
qu'aussi la consommation d'énergie et
d'électricité est aussi lié la richesse
des pays parce qu'on en a besoin
également pour faire tourner notre
industrie donc on se bagarre là dessus
on verra bien sûr jamais transigé avec
les questions de sécurité se ferment de
gros efforts la sécurité mais il faut
également faire de la recherche ou pour
que l'innovation soit la plus
performante et que tout le monde se
rende compte que le nucléaire c'est pas
l'ogre des grands-parents de 1,70 m et
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
positif à condition évidemment qu'il
soit traité avec rigueur comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui avec l'ensemble des
organismes qui travaillent à vérifier
que tout se passe bien dans le domaine
du nucléaire au sein de l'union
européenne
le secteur nucléaire présente aussi un
coup aujourd'hui une bataille politique
s'annonce entre les différents pays
européens pro ou anti nucléaires l'enjeu
c'est faire entrer ou non l'énergie
nucléaire dans la taxonomie verte
européenne qui vise à classer des
activités économiques qui permettent de
délimiter celles qui peuvent être
considérées comme durables sur le plan
environnemental
alors j'imagine que vous militez pour
que l'énergie nucléaire soit fasse
partie de cette taxonomie verte
européenne
alors effectivement il n'y a aucune
raison de retirer l'énergie nucléaire de
la taxonomie à la taxonomie en fait je
rappelle ce que c'est c'est pas de
l'argent public européen la taxonomie
c'est un classement des énergies par
rapport à l'objectif de décarbonation
pour permettre à des capitaux privés de
pouvoir investir dans ces domaines là
sur recommandation de deux banques
d'investissement par exemple donc en
fait
la place d'une équerre et bien donc
puisque ça va nous atteindre ça va nous
permettre d'atteindre l'objectif de
décarbonation en 2050 évidemment la
taxonomie doit intégrer nucléaire et
nous y veillons particulièrement il y a
dix lobby anti-nucléaire très
minoritaire mais très agressif donc il
va falloir s'organiser plus comme on
peut aussi à tout le monde que la voix
du bon sens de l'emporter sur la
taxonomie merci beaucoup christophe
grudler d'avoir été avec nous dans un
europe
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputés membres du groupe prignon
europe et membre de la commission de
l'industrie de la recherche de l'énergie
au parlement européen
sous drop
les superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine au
blé toutes les traditions que l'on
trouve en france sont souvent d'origine
paysanne ou marine parce que avant l'ère
industrielle
on cultivait les champs pour ce pour
vivre la première superstition qui vient
à l'esprit c'est le blé c'est celle qui
est liée au blé le blé qui porte bonheur
donc une des
superstitions qui est toujours respectée
aujourd'hui quand les gens pour
construire une maison le maître
charpentier quand la facture est achevée
va installer au fait de la maison un
epide une petite germe de blé
donc ça c'est porte-bonheur mais aussi
l'autre tradition qui étale qui est
d'aller cueillir dès qu'il ya des champs
de blé des épis de blé pourra faire un
petit bouquet porte-bonheur pour la
maison selon les traditions on va en
mettre 7 ou 9 mais il faut que le blé
soit absolument mur pas de blé vert à
l'intérieur il ne serait pas
porte-bonheur mais beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui encore offre des petits
bouquets de l'écorcé litige j'ai une
autre tradition qui consiste à auffay à
offrir
à pau avec du blé germé pour que vous
voyez pousser donc ça c'est aussi un
gage de bonheur si on a doublé qui
pousse dans sa maison zone europe c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui merci aux
équipes techniques du parlement européen
de bruxelles vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en podcast audio et vidéo sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensations et aussi sur tv 78 rendez
vous la semaine prochaine très bonne
soirée à tous
sous une robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france